And I was reading this other book while back as well,
which was written by the guy who ran the heat human genome project.
And I don't remember exactly what it was called,
but it was something like a scientist's case for God.
There's something like that.
And one of the things he referred to,
which didn't strike me as hard as it should have to begin with,
was the he,
he,
he thought that one of the phenomena say that justified a belief in a
transcendent being with something like the moral intuition of human beings that,
you know,
we have a sense of right and wrong and uh,
it's certainly what happens in genesis and the story of Adam and eve is that,
that that story announces the coming of the sense of right and wrong,
right?
The knowledge of good and evil.
And it isn't something we ascribed to animals.
It's something that's unique to human beings.
Animals can be predators and you know,
and they can be gentle and,
and you can have a relationship with them,
but you never think of an evil cat or you know,
or an evil wolf.
Even though they're,
you know,
they're predatory.
Um,
but human beings,
we have this capacity to judge between good and evil,
right and wrong.
And it's really an integral part of our,
our being.
And I think you can make an evolutionary case for that,
a biological case for that as you can make a biological case for most of what is
relevant about human beings because we're biological creatures,
but we don't really understand the significance of that.
Like what happens in the story of Adam and eve is that,
that's that realization that coming to the knowledge of good and evil is
actually represented as a shift of cosmic significance,
right?
It puts a,
it puts a permanent fracture in the structure of [inaudible].
And you know,
if you think of human beings as insignificant and so on,
a tiny dust mote in the middle of an infinite cosmos,
a cosmos that cares less for us,
then who cares?
Fundamentally,
if human beings have the knowledge to distinguish between good and evil.
But if you give consciousness a central role in being,
and you can make a perfectly reasonable case for that,
because without consciousness there's no being as far as anyone can determine.
So it may be much more central than we think.
And,
and,
and I,
I really don't think there's a counter argument to that,
like not a solid one.
You can state that consciousnesses epet phenomenal and,
and that the world is fundamentally materialistic.
And it doesn't matter that there's consciousness,
you can state that,
but you can make an equally credible case.
The other way,
and certainly our lived experience is that consciousness is crucial obviously.
And we treat each other as if most of the time we're valuable conscious beings
and we wouldn't give up our consciousness even though it's often consciousness
of suffering.
And so then I think another problem with the book is that it's,
it's sort of predicated on the idea that life is for happiness.
And I don't think that's right.
And I don't think that's how people experience life.
And I might be wrong,
but it seems to me that people experience life as something like a series of
crucial ethical decisions.
It's something like that.
I mean,
when I just can't imagine,
maybe I'm being naive about this,
but I can't imagine that.
I can't imagine another being that's like me in most senses,
that isn't constantly wrestling in some sense with what the next proper thing to
do is.
It's not like it's obvious.
It's not bloody obvious and it doesn't mean you'll do the right thing cause you
don't law lots of times and you know that by your own judgment,
right?
Cause you're making mistakes all the time.
Sometimes you don't know what you're doing and maybe it's a mistake and maybe it
isn't.
And who's to say that isn't what I'm talking about.
I'm talking about when you know that what you're doing is wrong and you go ahead
and do it anyways.
People do that all the time.
And that's also extremely peculiar.
Bloody well think that if you knew it was wrong and you told yourself that it
was wrong,
that that would be sufficient so that you would just wouldn't do it.
But that isn't what you're like at all.
You know?
And you can tell yourself something is wrong a 50 times and you'll do it the
51st time and then you'll feel,
you know,
like,
like you deserve to feel probably and,
but it doesn't stop you.
And so,
so then I think the other problem with the,
the viewpoint,
the idea that the suffering of life eradicates its utility is that it's
predicated on the idea that happiness or lack of suffering even is,
is the right criteria by which to judge life.
And I don't think that's how we actually experience life.
I think what we do instead is put ourselves through a series of excruciating
moral choices.
You know?
And one of the things that that's really significant about the biblical stories
and I think about the,
the entire implicit philosophy,
you know,
that's embedded in the stories,
is that that's how life is presented in the stories,
is all of these individuals,
first their individuals to not groups.
And second,
they're agonizing over their moral choices all the time,
all the time.
And they have a relationship with God.
And,
but it's not,
it's not a directive relationship.
Exactly.
Even the people to whom God speaks directly,
which I suspect is not something you'd exactly want to have happen,
is it's,
there's still the f even the fact that they have a direct relationship with God
doesn't stop them from being tormented continually by their moral choices.
And so the world is presented as a moral landscape,
not as a,
not as a place that justifies itself by happiness.
It's presented as a moral landscape and people are presented as creatures who
traverse through the moral landscape,
making ethical decisions that determine the course of the world.
And that seems to me to be right.
And that's not a,
that's not the same as happiness by any stretch of the imagination.
It's a whole different category of being and,
okay.
And then I've thought that through a lot and I think,
well,
we do make choices and what we do is contend with the future,
you know,
and the,
the future seems to appear to us as a realm of possibility.
It that's a more accurate way of thinking about it then then that the future
presents itself to it.
To us as a realm of determined things.
It's,
it's presents itself as a realm of possibility and there's good choices in that
realm and there's poor choices or even evil choices in that realm.
And we're negotiating continually deciding which of those choices we're going to
bring into being.
That seems to me to be phenomenologically indisputable.
And we certainly treat each other as if that's what we're doing because we hold
each other responsible for our actions,
you know,
with some exceptions.
And that we're deciding each moment whether to make things better or worse.
And
that seems to me to be correct.
And I think that that's what these stories illustrate.
They don't say that directly,
you know,
although I think it gets more and more explicit as the narrative unfolds.
But,
and then part of the realism of the stories,
is that right?
Yes.
The people aren't,
the people that are being presented are by no means good.
I mean,
maybe with the exception of Noah,
Noah seem to be a pretty good guy.
All they did,
he did get drunk and you know,
and,
and end up naked exposed to his sons and so forth.
But I mean,
yeah,
he,
he isn't talked about a lot as a character.
It's a pretty compressed story.
But Abraham,
I mean,
Abraham had plenty of problems,
not least of which was in his inability to leave home.
And then,
you know,
he's lying about his wife and there,
there's all sorts of mistakes.
And then Jacob,
who we're going to talk about tonight is an even more morally ambivalent
character.
He's,
especially at the beginning of the story,
he's,
it's,
he isn't the sort of person that you would pick out.
Especially if you are a hack writer.
You wouldn't pick him out as the hero of the story.
He does a lot of things that are really pretty reprehensible and take some,
an awful long time to learn better.
And yet he's the person who's put forward as the father of the 12 tribes of
Israel.
It's from this flawed person that the people that,
that maybe that,
whose story you might say is at the fundamental constitutes the fundamental
underpinning of our culture.
It's from this deeply flawed individual that that group emerges.
And so you might think of it out as a relief too,
because you know,
you're no knight in shining armor,
you know,
with,
with the,
with the pure moral passed.
I mean,
people make mistakes of catastrophic proportions nonstop,
you know,
and that also means that these stories put forward something approximating hope
because in their realism,
in their moral realism,
they present heroes,
I suppose the heroes of renowned,
right?
The Patriarchs of old,
let's say,
who are realistic,
people who have fits of anger and rage and who are murderous at times and who
are deeply,
deeply embroiled with family dispute and,
and who,
who have adulterous affairs.
And,
and like they do all of the terrible things that people do.
And the weird thing is,
is that God is still with them.
And
you know,
it isn't obvious what that means or even if it means anything,
but it's very,
it's not disputable as far as I can tell that a we're conscious and that
consciousness is a transcendent phenomena which,
which we do not understand.
And that the landscape that we traverse through his moral,
like every story you ever watch,
anything that grips your imagination on the screen or in the theater,
like any story that grabs you is a story of moral striving.
It's just not interesting otherwise.
Right?
The person has to be confronted with complex moral choices and then you see the
outcome and you know,
the good guy does it right in the bad guy does it badly and things don't go so
well for the bad guy generally.
And if it's a bit more sophisticated,
the good and the bad are in the same individual.
And that's,
you know,
that's a more compelling story.
But
so we could say,
well,
let,
let's,
we could make the assumption that it might be worthwhile thinking of the world
as a,
as it has been thought of classically as a theater upon which the forces of good
and evil continually strive for dominance.
And I,
for the life of me,
especially after I started reading deeply into 20th century history and all the
terrible things that happened in the 20th century and all the terrible,
unbelievably incomprehensible things that people did to one another,
I just couldn't see seeing things any other way is realistic.
You know,
because I don't think that you can immerse yourself in 20th century history
without coming to the conclusion that evil is a reality.
And if it's a reality,
it depends on what you mean by reality.
But it's fundamental enough reality for me.
And if it's a reality,
then I don't see how you can escape from the conclusion that the cosmos,
as we experience it,
at least is a place of moral striving.
And well,
that's one of the things that's really illustrated in the story of Jacob.
And,
and I found that quite striking.